i know your dog just had the surgery you
both just had surgery
i know can you believe that i mean i
broke my leg
well i had this scooter you know some of
god's kids
take the long way home
i had a scooter broke my leg if you
google mark lowry motorcycle wreck
you can hear several versions of that
story
uh and then you'd think okay well i got
rid of that one i sold it to a guy in
dallas
i've sold it to someone i didn't know
because i didn't want to hear about it
when they die
and this guy in dallas bought it came
down picked it up and i was in my
wheelchair telling him you really
shouldn't do this
but he bought it he said i'm i'm okay
and then
uh so a few years pass and my old age
memory goes bad and i forget
i shouldn't be riding motor scooters
i shouldn't especially shouldn't be
riding them in houston but i did i
bought four more
just because i don't like to scoot alone
and i all my friends go with me so but
this particular day i had gone
down uh to get a pedicure actually
i'm at the age where i've got to ask
myself do i want to cut my toenails or
do i want to breathe
[Laughter]
so i get pedicures at my age and
and i'm driving home two blocks three
blocks from the house
and this old man thought the stop sign
was a suggestion
and he hit me broadside and
i was looking down when he hit me it
wasn't going real fast but he's going
fast enough to knock the
license plate off his car and break my
foot
and so uh yeah i'm going through so i
had surgery the next day
and i've had two surgeries on that on
that foot and the next day the next
weekend
after that wreck i sold all four of
those scooters
yeah i believe it i wonder why yeah i
gotta find a new way to entertain myself
at 62. i can't have as much fun as i
used to
you broke your your leg twice on
scooters haven't you i have the same leg
gosh that thing is so tired of carrying
the gospel
[Laughter]
well we'll uh we're gonna we'll jump in
here i'm gonna do a quick intro
and then when i say no worries no when i
when i say your name uh we will be live
my friend you haven't recorded any of
this no we're recording we're just not
live streaming yet
oh you're gonna live stream yeah we're
gonna go on our youtube channel
you want me to live stream too yeah how
do you do that
well i can do it on my phone can i yeah
wouldn't that be fun liz we'll kick that
old devil's butt
he thought he had us
and we're going live on three different
platforms now
okay deliver us from even we'll do it on
facebook then all right
say what yeah it's facebook i do it on
facebook you go live on uh
all right let me think how i do this on
my phone again thanks for watching hot
breath the verse
if you want to support the show go join
our patreon but if you don't like
supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click to watch more videos to
keep us alive in the
hot
algorithm